All right, we are live.
Hi everyone, may name is Mark,
I am co-chair at Udacity for
the intro to programming nano-degree.
Joining me online is Luke.
He is also another co-chair.
And today, we're just going
to do a little broadcast and
talk about functions.
What are functions, how do we use
functions, what are the tips and
tricks to use functions and
what are the common gotchas and
the common things that you need
to lookout for in functions.
The majority of everyone will
be learning Python, right now.
And you will be learning functions or
have learned functions.
And we feel like this is
a very important concept,
such as, much like loops and decisions
things like if and else statements.
These functions make up a core,
I think a very very core
core concept in programming.
What do you think Luke, like,
how important are functions,
pages, in programming?
>> Without.
So functions are.
I mean,
they are one of the most basic things.
They're one of the most foundational
things you do in programming.
Everything you do,
if you're a competent programmer,
will involve writing lots and
lots of functions.
They're, sort of one
of the smaller bits of
the programming world that
you will use constantly.
It's very very foundational,
it's something that you have to,
you really should make sure that you
understand very well about what it is,
how to use it, everything like that.
>> Yeah.
Great thanks for your viewpoint Luke.
I agree with you,
if functions do not exist,
we would not be able to
program as efficiently and
as elegantly as we can in this world.
So again if you want, one that you
should walk away from this broadcast
is functions are very important and
you should invest the time into
practicing creating as many functions
as you can because trust me,
trust us, this will help you with it for
the rest of your programming career.
Great, so
we're going to start doing our,
start to talk about our presentation.
So, but if you have any
questions relating to functions,
please post these online and we'll
address these questions for you as well.
So Luke you have the floor.
>> Okay.
So the first thing that we
really should establish from,
we're talking about functions,
is exactly what a function is.
So functions which we'll also probably
refer to as procedures since they're
the same thing in Python.
They're bits of code that
you can call repetitively.
And generally when you think
about functions you're thinking
about something with defined input and
defined output.
But foundationally in Python
functions are something that you can
define once and
then use as many times as you'd like.
So if I were to screen
share a little bit here.
So the first thing,
as far as using functions that you
should know, is how to make them.
So you start a function
with the keyword def,
that's your definition of the function.
Then you give it some name.
The name would be some function here and
then these two parentheses
are necessary for a function.
It is where you would define
some parameter if you had one.
We'll go over what those are later.
But you need here because
we're going to use just
a function with no parameters what so
ever.
Then you need a colon and
then whatever is inside that indentation
is going to be your function.
That's going to be the code you can
reuse however often as you want.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Sorry to interrupt you, but
I just want to really emphasize how
important indentations are in Python.
You will find some other programs,
they don't care about indentation, but
in order to be able to define your
functions appropriately you need
to indent all the lines that
belong in your function or
else your function will not work.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> And
as we're going on with indentation,
it's un-indenting back to
where the function was,
the same level the function is to
find out that ends the function.
You can also end the function with
a return statement, which we'll go over
later, but that's not really ending
where the definition would end,
that's just ending where
the code will stop running.
But in Python,
the function end is where it unindents.
But so as we were kind of
going over with the function,
you give it some code to run in here.
So let's just say we're going to print.
Hello world.
So that's what the function does.
Now to call the function you simply
call it by saying the name no def,
no colon here and with the given
parameters you're going to use.
So if I were to run this, which I
obviously had right before we started,
I'm going to get the output,
Hello World.
In fact, I can do this however many
times I want with calling the function.
And it will run three times here,
three times.
Hopefully all that's visible for
you, but yeah.
So now as we keep going here,
there's a few things to note about
functions that are very important.
Functions create something
called a local scope.
So a variable that you make inside
of a function doesn't exist
outside of the function.
This is in contrast with
a global scope where
some variable that you make
will be available at all times.
So as a quick example of that,
let's just
make some function that does
something pretty simple.
So here we're having a global
variable called a = 6, and
we're having a local
variable called a = 5.
So both variables are named a but
they're not the same variable.
So we can see that when
we're running our function,
printing out a string,
that prints out a and
remember we redefined a here as equal
to five and then after our function is
done running, we can print
what the global variable is.
And as we run that whole thing, you'll
see that inside the function a = 5 and
then outside,
a = 6 because it never got redefined.
This a has nothing to do with this a.
Although they have the same name,
they don't point to the same object.
One thing to note here is that this a
right here, after we run some function,
it's destroyed.
It ceases to exist.
So that's,
with how global works if we were
to take out this a equals five,
you'll notice that the functions
should still work.
All of a sudden we're just using the
global version of a since we never make
a local version of a.
However, if we take out this
this string a right here.
Is going to produce an error.
So I make this a little larger.
It runs this successfully and
then when it gets to here,
this A isn't, doesn't exist anymore.
It's gone.
So this produces an error
saying that A is not defined.
The reason again why that happens is
this A is global it can work anywhere.
This A is local,
it only works inside the function.
So for a way around that we have
something called parameters
as far as how we're going to
get in some variable that we
actually want to use inside the function
without relying on global variables.
So as a quick aside here,
global variables are generally
a big no no in programming.
Sometimes you're going to end up using
them just because they're easiest for
the short thing you're doing.
But you should if there's a way
to avoid global variables,
avoid global variables,
always stick to local variables because
then you can't screw something up that
you don't think you're going to
screw up with your function but.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So on to parameters.
So I'll just copy and paste this quick.
A parameter is some value that
can be passed into a function.
So here,
I made some same name as a function
that I pass in parameter_1 and
parameter_2.
So when you actually do that to call it,
those values can be anything you want.
So it doesn't have to like, they don't
have to be called parameter one or
parameter two, you don't have to pass
a variable that has that same name.
All you have to do is put them in
order and they both have to exist.
So if I were to run this,
I'm going to get.
First I'm going to run print parameter_1
which you can see is Hello World here.
And the second thing I'm going to get
is 2 since that's what I passed in for
paramenter_2.
Now if I only gave this Hello World,
what's going to happen is that
I'm going to get an error.
Because the function takes two
parameters, arguments another name for
parameters here, and
then I only gave it one.
So that's always something you
have to watch out for here.
This can also be done with variables.
So let's say instead
of passing in Hello World I want to pass
in a variable that says Hello World.
And then b = 2, so I'll get the same
thing here by passing in two variables,
the same way I would have with just
the print function as a print statement.
Where that will once again
pass in a the value of a to
parameter one and
the value of b to parameter two.
One quick thing to note here is what
happens to parameter one doesn't affect
a because these are things that
are called immutable objects.
So if you've, depending on how far
you've gotten into the course,
you'll have found things like lists and
dictionaries to be mutable objects as
opposed to immutable objects which are
things like string, ints, floats, your
standard variables that you probably
use the most that aren't containers.
So a good quick starting point for
mutability is a good understanding
of variables themselves.
So here if I can just open
up interpreter here and
do this more easily that way.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I run it straight from straight from
the command line here at the terminal.
So just running Python.
So with the variables, a variable points
to a value that it holds in Python.
So, say I have a = 5, a is,
no, that was supposed to.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, it's already running Python, a = 5.
a now is a variable that
points to the value of five.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Sorry.
When you change an immutable value for
an immutable variable what
you're doing is you're changing
what the thing points to.
So you're not actually
changing the constant five,
you're changing a to
point to some new value.
So I can see this with the id function.
This gives me what it's pointing to.
If I were to just change that to six,
what I get, if I say id (a),
is a completely,
notice that this is different than this.
That it's pointing to
an entirely different object.
So five here being an object and six
being an object where they're explicitly
not the same thing that's been
pointed to, they're different values.
Now if I tried that same
thing with a mutable object.
So let's just say a list of some sort.
So now I'm going to say a is
some lists and I take id of a.
I can alter that list.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So just to show its altered,
it's now that.
And I get the exact same value for
id of a.
It points to the same object.
The list is still the same list.
It's just mutated.
It's changed.
>> Hey Luke.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you increase the font size a bit?
>> Gotcha.
So quick overview of what I did,
now with legible font sizes.
When I switched a from equaling five
to six ints which are immutable values,
the id actually changed.
Because six and five are constants.
They didn't change the pointer
that a referred to had to.
Now when I made it a list,
the id did not change when I changed the
list because the list itself changed.
Instead of the pointer.
So that's that's how variables work as
far, in Python, and that's going to have
pretty dramatic effects with what
we're doing with functions here.
So moving back to sublime.
If I pass in an immutable variable or
a mutable variable to a function.
What happens to the variable inside
the function happens to it outside.
When I pass in an immutable variable,
you can see with the very
word immutable that variable,
what happens inside the function does
not affect what value is passed in.
So let's just write up a quick
little part to show this.
Let's have some function and
give it some list as a parameter.
Inside the function we can just append.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
On to the list and then let's print
out what a local variable that is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now if we define some list over here and
then pass it into the function.
A is our parameter here.
It's given to some list.
Then what happens when we
print out A after that?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Notice that what happened
inside also happened outside.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That same exact thing does
not happen if I were to,
say, give this the value of five.
And even though we're calling it
some list, I just add one to it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
As previously demonstrated the Local
changes to 6, the Global does not.
It's not altered.
The immutable object is not
mutated inside the list.
This instead the some_list the parameter
becomes a Local variable even though
a was a Global variable a parameter
some_list which is given the value
of a is now a local variable.
It's destroyed at
the end of the function
a itself is not altered because of that.
So what do we want to do if
we want to actually get out
some value from function for
something of a value.
Well that's where return statements
come from or come in so let's just
change this it doesn't say list because
that looks bad for readability purposes.
So with some value some value here
let's say I want to actually change the
value there and get something out of it.
Let's return some lists return
does exactly what it looks like.
It gives the variable back.
So how I would do that is I would
assign some variable here, X,
and then X takes
whatever this variable was here,
and it just takes the value.
So, quickly doing that.
>> I think you need to change
some_list to some_value.
>> Yep.
>> And one more on line 2.
Yes.
There you go.
So I didn't actually do
anything with x here.
Well I did yes I did I printed it out.
So this is the value taken
from the returned value.
So one cool thing here is you can
actually return multiple values here.
So that's technically
returning a couple.
As you can see if I do this again.
It gives it a tuple value to X.
But at the same time I could
do something like this, and
it will actually understand
what I want to do there.
X will just take the first value of Y,
and Z are not equal to 1 and
2 because that's what I returned.
So a return value also stops
the function wherever it's at so
if I added that at the end of it.
This will never be read because
it's afterwards a return statement
Notice nothing changed
when I built that.
The high right there
simply doesn't get read.
It exists as part of
the function definition.
But because it comes after a return in
the sequence that the programs run.
So the program will run this line,
then this line, and then this line.
This line will end the program.
And it will never see the print high.
So you can do multiple things
with the returned value.
For instance,
you can print it out directly.
So let's just take out
these print statements.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So I could print what's returned
from some function here, and
I'll get a couple that's returned.
I'll get some value one too.
So I don't even have to save
it in about a variable.
I can also just run it and here nothing
would happen since that is printed
out and assigned basically not assigned
what's returned to anything anything if
that's if I'm looking for something that
the function did in here to say some
mutable value that I wanted changed but
didn't actually care what was returned.
I don't have to deal
with what's returned but
it's generally useful to
deal with what's returned.
That's actually a very important thing
sometimes as a beginner a lot of people
might get a little confused with the
difference between print and returns.
So print simply this console right here
print simply says puts whatever value
you're printing on to that console it.
It literally prints to what
you as a human can read
it doesn't alter
the state of the program.
It doesn't alter the flow of
how the program is running.
All it does is show you something
that you want from program.
Return on the other hand has
absolutely nothing to the console,
it ends a function and
brings that value from that function to
some external variable if you
assign it to an external variable.
Which actually brings
me to another thing.
Let's say I don't return anything.
I return nothing.
What do you think will happen here?
First I have to print X.
Notice that even without returning
anything what happens is that I
end up returning none.
I can even do that without
the return statement.
So it still returns none
because in Python none is,
it's what would be
considered a null value.
Null in other programming
languages is often what's used
in what Python is none.
It's essentially a value
that has no value.
It has the value it has is none.
Its literally its own value type so
it's not a string it's
just a value none the same is true and
false would be Boolean's.
But all functions or
procedures in Python returns something
by which I mean if you don't assign
a returned you returned none.
So if you ever get none where
you weren't expecting it,
when you're trying to print something.
That's probably a sign that
you're possibly printing, or
you meant to return, or
something like that where
you're printing the value from
a function that doesn't return anything.
Sometimes you explicitly
want to return none.
That that tends to be the case when you
are testing explicitly to see if
you get to a state in the program.
It's a nice default holder, since it
doesn't really take up any space.
As far as if you're going to
change some value into say a list.
It's a nice default value which
we want to get into here but
it has its uses but
that's that's sort of the main point.
That's one of the reasons
actually that Python
doesn't have a difference between
procedures and functions.
So in math a function is
something which maps some unique
input to some output for example F
of x = nx + b equation of a line.
In programming languages the functions
tend to be something pretty similar.
It takes input in the form
of parameters/arguments and
it gives output from what it returns.
But in some programming languages
functions don't actually affect
anything other.
Like outside of that,
if there are no mutatable values,
then what happens in the function
stays in the function.
It only has parameters and
input and output.
On the other side of that in some other
programming languages procedures might
just be sort of subroutines, things that
you run that don't return any values but
which just do something to
other values in the program.
By the way, a quick aside.
When a function does do things other
than take input and give output,
it actually alters some mutable values.
We call that alteration
a side effect of the program.
So sometimes a side effect of
the function, I should say.
Sometimes you are literally, a side
effect of the function is the whole
point, so
it's sort of a misnomer in that effect.
But that it's a piece of terminology
you might find useful at some point.
Another reason why Python procedures and
functions aren't actually different is
that you'll notice that since every
function returns something there
isn't like a true procedure
that doesn't return anything because
you implicitly returned none.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Did you have anything to add Mark?
>> Other than the fact that
we've noticed a lot of people
get confused between print
statements and return statements.
And yeah it's really
like to likely emphasize
print is really different from return,
they are two different things.
The only common thing is they
get you some sort of value.
Then you have to,
you manipulate this value because
a lot of people will create a function
and then they'll print the function.
They run and they print it and
they're like okay that's the value that
I got from my function but in essence
you're running a print statement and
then you're returning none.
So it's a very subtle difference but
I think it's worth reemphasizing.
>> Okay.
>> And yeah, it looks like
we don't have any questions,
it looks like our viewers ate,
they're getting it.
We hope everyone is getting it.
Can you show us an example of
multiple returns statements?
What would that look like?
>> Okay, so let's screen share again.
So I'm assuming you're referring to and
if statements?
>> Yeah if statements,
like that's a very common way to do it.
>> Okay, so let's say.
>> Can you increase size
of the text right there?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
[CROSSTALK] The window is like
small Luke, like the window itself.
Can you increase that window?
There we go, yeah, yeah better.
>> That's weird to me because
the window is actually bigger
just now than it was for
most of the presentation.
>> Okay.
>> Who knows, weird quirks.
So a lot of times you can have returned
different things depending on what
you're doing.
Let's, actually return the type,
like let's return different things
based on the type of some value.
So with Python we don't actually
have to specify what type our
parameters are for a function.
Which is a lot different than
a lot of other languages.
Say, in C or C++ or Java,
you're going to have to specify that
say if you want an integer here,
you're going to actually have to specify
that you want an int in that spot.
So the program doesn't crash, but
here we can return different
things depending on whether or
not we have an int.
And then we can just maybe
return a value of that int
verses if we have
something that's not an int.
We can just return
a straight string like that.
And then we can run on this function
on a variety of different things.
So let's say 25, that should get one.
Actually let's print all these out so
that we can see what we have.
And then let's print.
Actually this should be fun.
25.0 since that should be a float.
We run this.
We'll notice that the first
one is an int and so
returns one, the second one is not an
int, so it returns a string, not an int.
We have different return statements here
because well we have an if statement
that goes from one place to another
depending on what some_value is.
Actually one big trip-up
that is found quite
a few times here would be something
like a while statement or a for loop.
So let's say I
want to just print that if statement or
some value ten times.
So let's make a counter.
I'll just do that for loop for
e in range (10).
If you do this, you're going to end up
only doing it once because the function
will end as soon as you get here.
So, it's only going to run once,
whereas if you had wanted to
print it out more times or
wanted to make some
list actually have it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You have to move the return
to outside of the for loop.
Inside the for loop,
anytime you hit that return,
it's going to end the function
even in the middle of a loop.
So that's one big thing to
remember about return statements.
A return statement ends
the function immediately.
Regardless of whether it's in
something that shouldn't necessarily.
You wouldn't think of ending without
ending that with something like
a for loop.
A return statement always
ends the function.
There's actually some fun things you
can to with return statements that
you won't really encounter so
much in this class,
although CS 101 has quite a bit
of it which is recursion.
So you technically don't need loops,
although Python's not particularly
well set up for recursion.
Because you could use
a function to call itself.
So instead of returning some value,
we could actually return
some function here.
Which you'll notice is going to be an
infinite loop because it's just going to
keep calling itself over and
over and over again.
But if we say, made an if statement
that, I just typed an if statement.
If we make an if statement that
has some base value that So
you can think of a recursion
sort of like in the same way
as a loop it has to have
stopping condition.
We'll call this a base case and
that stopping condition is
what sort of ends the loop.
And then there the recursion
will sort of and
then keep each value will be finally
returned to the function that called it
and then at last you
are function will end.
One of the reasons Python's actually
not particularly well suited for it
is that it was actually kind of welding
on the scope of this class but it.
Each function has a certain amount of
overhead and you just straight up run
out of memory for how many
functions are simultaneously called
instead of one function ending and
then calling the next one.
So a while loop doesn't
really take up much memory.
It just keeps on going over and over.
Whereas recursion takes up a lot of
memory in something like Python.
Should I demonstrate
an actual recursive case?
>> Yeah, just something very simple.
>> Okay.
>> Would suffice.
>> Okay, so let's say.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's make a counter here.
Take this out.
So if count = 0, we're going
to have that be our base case
just return some value else.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Return.
Some function.
Some value plus one plus one.
So this is kind of a pointless
function but we can call it anyway.
>> [CROSSTALK] Minus one, right?
Yeah.
>> Yes.
Well, unless I start with
a negative number that would,
recursion has the same fun with loops
is, only it takes a little bit getting
used to in your head about if
I started out with a count.
Bigger than zero.
If I had plus one here
it would never end.
It would just get basically
an infinite loop but
an infinite loop that ends more
quickly than normal because
Python will tell me that hey
I'm completely out of memory.
But then I can do that and see what
I get out for my final value here.
It looks like and I needed that.
Yay.
So it returns every value between 25 and
35 because I print some
value every time and
then ten is how many times
I'm going to call itself.
And then it simply adds
one to count every third,
subtracts one to count
until we get to zero.
When we get to zero,
it actually prints some value.
To show you how the difference between
this and a normal infinite loop.
If I were to actually give this,
let's just give it a negative number so
it destroys itself nice and quick.
Notice that it actually hit the maximum
recursion depth pretty quickly.
You could be sitting in an infinite
loop wondering if your program's just
slow for minutes if you have
a particularly involved
program that has to go through
a fantastically large argument of data.
But with recursion,
if you go too deeply,
the program will basically cut itself
off right there in only half a second.
The main problem with that is that
if you actually have a lot of stuff
you have to go through the program
cuts itself off in half a second and
you'll never get through all of it.
It will just make an error even though
theoretically that shouldn't have to be
one if you had a computer
with infinite memory.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But that's just a quick aside there
it's a pretty recursion something and
using algorithms quite a bit for
at least like saying graph theory.
It's pretty useful.
It's easier to think of in
certain cases obviously loops
actually tend to be faster
in almost all languages.
So sometimes where you use recursion and
anything that's possible with
recursion is also possible with loops.
But sometimes it's easier
to set up recursion and
then it is to set up a loop and so It's
useful to do something with recursion
because it's simply much easier to.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Shall we do another recursive thing
that maybe has a point or should I?
>> I think I think we're good Luke,
yeah.
We don't want to overload our students.
But I think that was a good, let me
switch to my broadcast
over here at the office.
Recursion is just another
way to use functions,
and once you get the hang up like
of knowing how to return things,
know how to process parameters arguments
and know how to process them and then
basically take these functions and use
something you're day to day programming.
Recursion will will start
to get making them a little
more sense especially if
it involved programs or
problems that involve algorithms or
any arrest type of mathematical or
calculation where you're not sure about
the length of like total calculations
like let's assume that I will not be
able to calculate ten things right.
I could just simply use a loop but
if I want to be able to calculate
It may be 10 things, it may be
15 things, it may be 120 things.
I don't know until I
actually execute it.
That's when recursion is
actually really, really useful.
But yeah, thanks Luke for showing us,
giving us a little sneak peek.
So again, in summary about functions.
Functions are again, very important.
These are the building
blocks of programming.
They're very, very basic ways to
increase your efficiency as a coder and
also to increase your power.
But again, these are the base
things that you need to know in
programming in order for you to be able
to do like any other fancy stuff that
you you may have seen that other
people have have done in programming.
You know, functions are made of,
you know, inputs and outputs.
So basically a function,
is a way to map an input to an output.
You take some sort of input,
we call that a parameter or an argument.
We do something to it and
we transform it in some way.
And then we give it an output,
we actually return it.
Or and or change the argument if it's
mutable variable such as a list.
We actually process it and
that's why procedures and
functions are used interchangeably
because again it's you're
changing something, and
you're either returning the variable or
you change the variable and
then you're just returning none.
>> What else?
800 things to,
there are still walk away with.
>> So functions again,
they're very, very foundational.
Make sure you have a good
grasp on functions.
It's always good to try
some stuff out yourself.
So, maybe try out some
stuff with local and
global scope thinking about what
those mutable valuable variables,
how they'll actually change depending
on what you do inside your function.
For instance the difference
between defining a new
mutable variable inside your function,
which would be local scope versus
changing that mutable variable that you
had from a global scope which
will be from the global scope.
It's good to play around
with this stuff, so
that's I suppose was my only
real recommendation there.
>> Awesome, well thanks Luke for
that awesome presentation yeah.
So hopefully you walk away watching
this broadcast and you're fired up, you
could just try it yourself, just create
functions and just practice with it.
Again, practice makes It's
very true in programming.
The world's your playground.
You just fire up your
Python interpreter and
just play around with
exactly what Luke did.
And hopefully you'll start to get a good
intuitive sense of what these
functions are in Python.
Great.
So we hope everyone got something
away from these functions.
I think next week, look at what,
what are we talking about next week.
Let's see.
Loading here.
So what's next week.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
19th would be next week,
I think it looks like it's style.
The importance of founding coding style
site, and then it was slower here.
So yeah, basically coding style for
HTML, CSS, and Python style.
So this is another very important
thing concept to learn is how do you
program in a good style that
makes your code readable and
sharable and
also makes it more organized?
Because I really think if how you
style and how you organize your code
tells a lot of about how
efficient your program can run.
That's what I'm a big big proponent of
making sure that your style, your your
variables define right, your organizing
your code cleanly and clearly.
It shows that you you have good
sense of what you're doing and
where you're going.
Awesome, well hopefully
we'll see you next week.
All right and thank everyone.
Bye.